[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So when
brainstorming how
to celebrate
International Women's Day,
we had a lot of
ideas about who we
wanted to bring to the
office, whether it's
an entrepreneur or someone who
is successful in corporate.
But what was really
important to us
was to bring someone
who was a shining
example of a successful
Arab woman and someone
from the region who
had spent their time
and spent their energy building
something really, really cool.
And so the theme for this
year's International Women's Day
is Balanced for Better.
And we couldn't think
of someone better
to have to talk about this
theme than Sarah Abdullah.
Sarah is the founder
of Makooky World
and is a successful
entrepreneur from the region,
has moved from corporate, and
has built her own business
in quite a short amount of time.
Makooky World is a
platform for children.
There's children's content in
the form of-- there's an app,
there's a YouTube channel, and
it's an interactive platform
that is all in Arabic.
And what's really
fantastic about it
is that there are a
lot of social messages
that are being conveyed
through this platform.
So I'll turn it over to Sarah
to talk a little bit more
about her journey and
Makooky World specifically.
You are the chief
writer, and the content
is very dear to your heart.
So I wanted to first start out
by understanding why Makooky?
And what it means to you?
SARAH ABDULLAH: First
of all, thank you very
much for having me here today.
It's an honor, especially
on Women's Day.
I take pride in
that, so thank you.
Why Makooky?
Because it's all about
stories and storytelling.
And storytelling has always
been so dear to my heart.
I think that since
the beginning of time,
people came together
around the fire
at the time because
of storytellers who
always had something to say.
And I think about
all the stories
that we're told that, at
a certain point in time,
were seen as
superpowers like, people
crossing seas, or climbing
mountains, or even flying.
And I think about
how those ideas
were transformed into words.
And how these words with
the repetition of them,
and when they're told
over and over again,
allow one person to take a
step forward and turn them
into action.
And I think the power of story,
as stories comes from here,
it's the fact that an
idea can become a word,
and a word can become an action
is why I find it so magical.
So for a very long time,
I appreciated that.
I wanted to tell stories.
I wanted to tell stories that
are dear to my heart that
can possibly create a change.
And what better way
to create change
than start with children?
Because they are the
adults of tomorrow.
So if we want to aspire to
something, we start young.
And that's where the idea of
creating content for children
came from.
I come from a
corporate background.
I started back in 2001.
I was at Leo
Burnett advertising.
And I worked there
for a very long time
until in 2014, I took
the step to quit.
And being in the corporate
world teaches you a lot.
It teaches you that
there is a structure.
Everybody can do
their job very well.
They learn how to do a specific
thing really, really well.
And I was a producer.
I produced TV commercials,
and radio commercials,
post-production, animation.
And I knew a little
bit about everything,
but a lot about production.
And being here today actually
reminds me of things I miss,
which is really funny
because we're talking
about corporate versus startup.
Seeing a room filled
with people who
have a laugh and a
wonderful culture.
And I'm sure all of you
connect all the time
and have great exchange.
And this is the part
that the corporate world
offers you, which is amazing.
But at the same
time, as beautiful
as the ship was, and as
safe, and it provided well,
it had a captain,
which was leading it.
And I didn't decide
where we were going.
And at a certain point in time,
I wanted to go somewhere else,
so I wanted to be captain
of my own boat at the time
so I decided to quit.
And I don't think
you quit in a day.
I think the idea to
leave where you are,
where you're kind of happy,
and you love your job,
and start something on your
own comes in different stages.
It's an idea that starts.
And I believe that ideas
grow and grow bigger,
and they just take over
at a certain point in time
where they become
your companion.
You wake up with this idea,
you sleep with that idea.
And everything you do is
reflective of that idea,
and that was Makooky.
Makooky actually is the name
of the company of the startup,
but it's the name of the
main character at Makooky
who is an alien who comes from
outer space, comes to Earth.
And because of his curiosity,
decides to travel and come
here, and sees the
world for the first time
with the eyes of a child.
And this character was
starting to build in my head.
And because of my
experience and production,
I could see how he looks like.
I could see where he can live.
I could see what
he will be doing.
And we befriended
each other for a year
before I decided to
leave what I was doing,
and just start a journey,
and begin my startup.
SPEAKER 1: So going from
that sort of concept phase
to where it is right now,
what was the process like?
And particularly, this
is a children's platform.
What were the themes
that you really
wanted to include and
make sure that we're
very prevalent in the
stories that you're telling?
SARAH ABDULLAH: The ideas was
to have children's content
in Arabic that is providing
stories, songs, activities
for the region.
But it was not a business,
in a sense, at the beginning.
So it was the character, and
then it was the type of content
that I wanted to
create that's made it
to a digital platform that then
transformed into a business.
And it was a very
important process for me.
Makooky is an application.
It has story songs for
children up to age 8.
They're provided in Arabic.
It's interactive, it's
animated, it's fun,
but that's not what it is.
It's not a place, a library
where we have content that
meets two criteria--
children and Arabic--
goes into.
That's not how we think.
It's a world on its own that
is supported by pillars.
And those pillars were
one of the first things
we thought about.
Those pillars are
reflective of the values
that Makooky stands for.
And these values are:
imagination, knowledge,
and responsibility because
we are talking to children.
And childhood is one of
the most crucial phases
in a human being's life.
And as a content creator,
we have the responsibility
to make sure that our messages
carry this responsibility
with a lot of care.
So the pillars were
there, then the characters
were born because
of those values.
So we have Makooky, our main
character, and his friends,
[? Mahoob, ?] [? Maluma, ?]
[? Masulla. ?] Each one
delivering one of those messages
in the stories or the songs
that we're producing.
And these values are very broad.
So imagination can mean
anything and knowledge can mean
anything, but what we had
to do is decide and define
the themes that would
live under those values.
So for us, imagination was
anything and everything
with no limitation
of time or space,
children can go wild regardless
of the many restrictions
that we do face
in the Middle East
and while talking
to our children.
This is not real, this is
not true, that is not right.
We don't care.
Let them imagine.
There is nothing
right with an idea.
Ideas can be
anything, and they can
be transformed into reality.
And that was the first concept.
Knowledge, for us,
needed to stay away
from preaching, and teaching,
and education in that sense.
Knowledge for us
was showing journeys
through storytelling
of trial and error,
failure, observation.
And that's how children learn.
And that was the knowledge
that is being collected.
Responsibility, we
spent a lot of time
on because again being
in the Middle East
and speaking to Arab
parents and Arab children,
a lot of the
responsibility values
are derived from our
traditions, from our values,
especially in this
part of the world.
And what we wanted
to do at Makooky
is give it a broader
look and feel.
We wanted to treat children
as responsible human beings
and global citizens.
So the subjects that fell under
responsibility in our stories
were not about just
respecting the elderly,
and being kind to the young,
and doing your homework
or anything, it
was responsibility
towards one's self,
health, well-being,
eating healthy,
nutrition, sports,
that's under
responsibility for us.
Responsibility towards the
creatures who we live with,
the animals, the plants, the
trees, the environment, that
fell under responsibility.
And most importantly,
responsibility
towards our dreams,
our aspirations.
So also within the
content creation,
we are very keen on
the presentation.
And I'm very happy
it's Women's Day.
And at Makooky, we take
pride at fair representation
of both males and females in
our stories and our songs.
Because I don't think that
stories and content needs
to be only reflective
of the culture
you're in, but also has to be
aspirational to where you want
to be and where you want to
arrive, especially when you're
working with children.
So we just released
actually a collection
of professions-- what kids
can be when they grow up.
And I'm very happy because
we had the ballerina story.
And it had a girl and a boy
because we often forget boys
when it comes to dancing.
And it might not be the
most acceptable thing now,
but there are male dancers,
there are boy dancers,
and we have to celebrate them,
and encourage them, and accept
that this is a choice
they're making.
We had a girl judge and
it exists, it's there.
They're a minority.
But girls and boys have
to look at those stories
and find it normal.
We have to normalize
what we want to get to.
And it's our job
as content creators
if we want something to
happen in the future,
we have to make it
normal today, visually.
We have to hear it, we have to
say it, we have to repeat it.
We had a girl astronaut.
I think it exists, but we
want to aspire to have more.
And that's how we deal with
content in Makooky World.
SPEAKER 1: And have
you found that there
is a reception to
portrayals of things
that are not traditional
in our part of the world?
SARAH ABDULLAH:
Yes, yes, there's
more reception than we think.
I think a lot of our
reaction to the market
is based on assumptions
of what exists.
So we look at what
exists, and then we say,
that's what the market wants,
that's what the market needs,
that's what the market
likes, but that's not it.
Give them what they
didn't see and then you'll
know whether they are
receptive to it or not.
And they might not be now, but
it's happening, it's a reality.
So do we just keep ignoring it?
Or do we take responsibility in
participating and contributing
to change?
Because it is up to us
to create this change.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
SARAH ABDULLAH: And
allow the educators
to have tools to provide
this visual, normalization
of change.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely,
absolutely.
So I want to go back to
this concept of being
the captain of your
own ship because I
think that's something
that each of us
individually,
whether we're working
in a corporate
environment, or thinking
about starting our own
thing, that comes to mind.
And maybe talk to
us a little bit
about your journey towards
actually taking that step
and thinking about what it is
that you truly wanted to do,
realizing what your passion was
because it's the challenge I
think a lot of people face.
SARAH ABDULLAH: Yeah, so I
knew I wanted to start Makooky.
And my experience was heavy
on writing, on production.
And I had to create something
that can turn into a business
because I wanted it to
live on a digital platform,
because I wanted to
change as much as I can.
And because this is the
future, this is the world,
and children love their apps.
And it's an interactive and
it's not a passive relationship,
but getting there is
a different story.
So a lot of the founders of
startups, as you may know,
start their businesses
because they love something.
So somebody who starts an
app about cars, for cars,
is probably a car lover,
but doesn't know much
about finance, or marketing, or
digital media, or legal setups,
and so on and so forth.
So it is very challenging
because when I had my idea,
and when I had all
the content ready,
and I worked with a developer
to create actually a prototype,
and I worked with
an animator, and I
put time and money into it.
So for an entire year
I created a prototype
of the app to be
able to go to market
and actually raise money.
And that process
is not very simple
because there's a lot of market
research that goes into it.
You have to put the
figures, you have
to understand how
much it'll cost.
You have to put the
figures in phases.
I didn't know what
the phases were.
I had to ask for a lot of
advice, for a lot of help.
I had to know who
was in the market.
Who are the major players?
What are they doing?
Is it working?
If it's not, why isn't it?
So a lot of validation
goes into place,
but then raising money is a
completely different story
because I'm a creative.
I'm a content creator.
I've done a lot of
budgeting for production,
but when you seek
investments, you're
kind of converting your words
into a different currency.
So I'm talking values, quality,
stories, change, social change,
and you have people
in front of you
who are thinking money, dollar
signs, profits, revenue.
And you're not going to
win if you don't convert.
You have to find a way
to convert everything
you're saying into a language
that is investment friendly,
otherwise it won't work.
And that process alone was very
difficult and very challenging
because it's not me,
it's not my element,
it's not what I'm good at.
SPEAKER 1: And it's new.
SARAH ABDULLAH: It's
a new field for me.
So that's where I
sought a lot of advice.
I had hours and
hours of rehearsals
with friends who are very
dear friends to my heart,
but were very good
at doing that part.
We role played, I got upset
because I told him to be honest
and they were, and
I became defensive.
So I went through rounds,
and rounds, and rounds
of presenting, getting
rejection, presenting,
getting challenged at a point
that I had no idea about.
And it was hard work because
everybody wants the founder
to go and pitch.
And I can pitch my idea, but the
business model, it's new to me,
and it's still a
work in progress.
Years later, it will
always be work in progress
because you're always more
comfortable in your element.
I can talk about Makooky,
the product, for hours.
And then I have to go and speak
about figures, and numbers,
and conversion.
And it takes more time,
but that's normal.
And I think it's
a challenge that
is shared by many founders.
And I think that we are always
reluctant to talk about it
because you always
don't want to seem
like you don't know
it all, but the truth
is you don't know it all.
Nobody knows it's all;
it's just impossible.
SPEAKER 1: And I think
there's a tendency for females
to be a little bit more
reluctant to take the step
to ask for advice, or to
seek help for challenges
that they're facing.
Has that been your experience?
SARAH ABDULLAH: Yes, if I
would give one advice to myself
three years ago, I would
say, seek more advice
without worrying about judgment.
So today I'm not
worried about judgment
because I just simply don't
care if I'm being judged or not.
What I care about is the
result of that conversation
because exchange
is very important.
But when I first started,
I was always thinking OK,
the product is not
there; it's not perfect.
I know I want to talk with X or
Y because they're very smart,
but if I ask them
questions, will they
just assume that this question
means I don't know anything?
Will they say, come
on, this was basic?
If she doesn't know
how to do this,
how is she running a
business if she doesn't
know this small finance?
If she has to ask
this finance question,
how is she running a business?
If she asks this tech question,
how's she running a business?
And you're always
worried because there
are two things you're doing.
You want to seek advice, but you
also want to prove your worth.
And these can become very
conflicting at times.
So there's always a conflict
on whether will this
give away and expose all
my lack of knowledge?
And is that smart to do?
But my advice is,
do it, it's OK.
One person can think
you don't know anything,
but what you get out
of that conversation
will make you know 50% more.
And when you speak
to another person,
you would have known 50%
more, and that's what matters.
SPEAKER 1: So speaking
of challenges,
I think everyone faces
this to a certain extent,
is balancing home life
and/or personal life
with being a founder, and having
basically your work kind of
follow you 24 hours a day.
So how do you do it?
SARAH ABDULLAH: I
don't have a balance.
So there is no
balance in my life
because balance means
things are equal,
and things are not equal.
My family comes first.
And so I do find the term,
work-life balance not something
that I go for.
I would say, how
do I manage it all?
I would talk about
time management
if that makes more sense.
So I'm a mother of two.
I became a mother of two
as I was starting Makooky
and building it.
And I have two beautiful
daughters, Clara and Ella--
four years and two year olds.
And Makooky is three years
old, so you can imagine
everything that goes into it.
At the beginning,
it was not easy
because you are overwhelmed.
A family doesn't
come with a manual,
nobody tells you what to do.
And they come, more people
come into your life,
and you're still stuck
with the 24 hour frame.
So they don't come
with more hours.
They don't come with
more nothing, nothing.
SPEAKER 1: Just
more responsibility.
SARAH ABDULLAH: Just
more responsibilities.
And so it was very
challenging at the beginning.
And it did throw things off
balance at the beginning.
And then I realized,
OK, the only way
to do it is to set the variables
and the constants in my life.
So there are constants
that will never disappear,
which is my relationship with
my children, my well-being,
and my deliverables at work.
And there are variables
that I can work with.
And these variables are
how do I optimize my time?
How do I become more efficient?
How do I meet my deliverables
at different hours,
different phases.
And I realized that you
can't do everything--
you can't.
It's impossible.
So you have two
delegate and accept
that there are people in your
life that will give you help,
and you can't take
credit for it.
So I have help at home who
are taking care of my children
when I'm working, and I'm not
going to take credit for that.
And I have people who--
at work, I have a wonderful
team who have ownership
because I delegated to them.
And they do a lot of the work.
And I have a partner,
and I'm am very lucky.
We are two parents who are
taking care of our children.
And all of this comes together,
and then you compromise.
So instead of cancelling
gym, I do 30 minutes instead
of an hour.
Instead of cancelling
seeing a friend,
I do a power breakfast
instead of a drink.
Instead of watching
movies, I watch series now
because they're much shorter.
So at nights, I have 30 minutes.
And you cut everything
short because it
is a pizza that's being sliced
and given to many more people.
You had it for your own, and
then everyone wants a piece.
And you just have to
have thinner slices.
But I don't know if
anyone has it right.
It is a compromise
on many levels, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So speaking
of these various avenues
where you spend
your time, are there
any particular ones that give
you inspiration or motivation?
SARAH ABDULLAH: Yeah, my kids
are my biggest inspiration.
I'm very lucky.
So, of course, it takes a lot
of time to raise children,
but because they're still
within the age, which
is also Makooky's target
audience-- it's amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
They were very helpful.
It's very helpful
for many reasons.
First, I can enter
play areas and observe
without being weird.
SPEAKER 1: Market research.
SARAH ABDULLAH: Because I
have my children with me.
Can you imagine an adult
just being there alone?
I call all their
friends for play dates,
and pass on the iPad,
and watch their behavior.
[LAUGHTER]
I have free access to mom
groups, and parent groups,
and fathers, and it's amazing.
They come with their own perks.
I shoot most of our
promotions with my children,
free of charge.
[LAUGHTER]
And I can post on social
media without consent forms.
[LAUGHTER]
I love it.
It's amazing.
It's amazing, really.
And it helps, but they also
have ideas of their own.
My four year old thinks she
works for Makooky because we do
a lot of office hours together.
SPEAKER 1: Technically
she does, right?
Technically she does.
SARAH ABDULLAH:
She comes to the office a lot.
I ask her to draw,
I ask her opinion,
and then I give
her money because--
[LAUGHTER]
--she skipped a play date.
So she actually thinks
she's getting paid.
And it's working, and--
[LAUGHTER]
--we have a lot of content
coming because of that.
AUDIENCE: Give her
a stock option.
SARAH ABDULLAH: I
should, I should.
[LAUGHTER]
I should but I've
worked so hard for that,
so I'm always in conflict.
But yeah, thank you
for giving me ideas.
[LAUGHTER]
It's good to have kids when
you're in this business.
It's good, it's
good to kids when
you're in this business--
that's all I can say.
So they are a very big
help and inspiration.
SPEAKER 1: So I have one final
question before I open it up
to the audience.
But there was actually
a recent study
that showed that less
than 20% of business
owners within the MENA
region are held by women.
And having started
your own company here,
is there any advice
or inspiration
you would give to those
who are aspiring to do so?
SARAH ABDULLAH: Yes, first,
I think that 20% is not
reflective of how many women
try to be entrepreneurs
and succeeded.
I think it's how many people
actually branched out, and were
brave enough to leave
the corporate world,
and be entrepreneurs.
And I think that this percentage
is low because of many factors.
And I really hope that
this will change soon
and everybody will
contribute to this change.
I think that there are a lot
of initiatives supporting
female entrepreneurs, female
led startups, and that's great,
but that's not where
the problem is.
The problem is to be able
to be an entrepreneur,
you have to have
leadership skills.
You have to take the
decision to be on your own.
And to be able to do that,
you should be confident enough
to do it.
And you should
also know that once
you do that, you are supported.
And unfortunately, we still
live in a society where there
is this type of upbringing
of girls where they're like,
don't do this, you're a girl.
Is she being too messy?
While boys fall, and bump
themselves, and climb trees,
and it's the norm.
It's like, it's
normal, he's a boy.
And then girls try to do the
same thing, and you're like,
are you sure?
She's too boyish.
She's too tomboyish.
I heard people
saying, maybe she's
hanging out with a lot of boys.
She's losing her femininity.
And all this girl was doing
was being curious, falling,
having more bumps, and hits,
and bruises, and that's normal.
That's childhood, it's
not about girls and boys.
And then you have
a lot of examples
from the corporate world
where there's still a pay gap.
And there is still difference
in the way women are promoted
to what leadership positions.
And most of the entrepreneurs
don't just graduate and become
entrepreneurs, but they
were working somewhere.
And what they've been
fed and trained to feel,
they continue and carry
onto their journey
in their entrepreneur life.
And also there's
the bigger problem,
which is the unfair
distribution of responsibilities
in families that is still
existing in our society.
Female parents and
male parents are not
expected to have the same
responsibilities at home.
And I'm not talking here
about role segregation.
I'm not saying a family
unit who consciously
decided we have a breadwinner
and we have a primary nurture.
I'm talking about
family units who
have a male breadwinner,
a female breadwinner,
plus primary nurturer.
How do you expect this
woman or this female
to do the same
amount of work when
given half the time that this
male is doing or achieving?
It is impossible.
So until we are conscious
of all of these factors,
and we speak up and
talk about them,
and put our foot down
and say, I am not
going to be with a partner
who does not do his share.
I am not going to
raise my daughters
with a cushion and a bubble.
And I'm not going to
give male attributes
to positive things and female
adjectives to negative things.
And until the corporate
world realizes and fixes
its pay gap and gender
opportunity problems,
these numbers are not
going to improve no matter
how many initiatives
support entrepreneurs
later on in life, really.
I think we have to go
back to the basics.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
All right to open it up
to audience questions.
Females?
It's International Women's Day.
SARAH ABDULLAH:
Maybe no questions.
SPEAKER 1: No questions?
AUDIENCE: I have one.
How can men specifically help
in what you were describing?
I mean, everyone has
their role in improving
what you're mentioning here.
Can men do something
more specific to try
to advance this?
SARAH ABDULLAH:
Yes, first of all,
thank you very much
for this question.
I don't think that
isolation works in any way.
I'll give you an example
from Makooky, actually,
because it is dear
to my heart, and I
keep having arguments
with everybody about it.
A lot of children's, or
forget children's-- apps
in, specific-- a of brands
who market for children speak
to women only when
advertising their products.
And I'm talking about
clothes, diapers, creams.
I saw a diaper ad where they
said, that should [ARABIC]
and fix it and [ARABIC] and fix.
And they're
excluding the father.
Fathers never change diapers.
I actually messaged
them, and, of course,
because it's very important
to talk about these things.
So at Makooky, we never
speak to mothers alone.
We never ever exclude fathers.
We say, your children
[ARABIC],, do this [ARABIC]..
We don't say, [ARABIC],, which
is something in Arabic where
you speak to females
only and exclude fathers.
Men can do a lot.
Men have to do a lot because
this is not only a woman's
thing, it's a men's thing.
First of all, I
think that men need
to start on a societal level
and change definitions.
So instead, not call
raising your children,
babysitting, or not saying
doing your part of the job,
helping your wife.
Because it's not a
husband-wife department,
it's a parent-parent department.
Standing up for your
colleagues at work
I think that if a male is
aware that a female colleague
of theirs is underpaid
or deserved a promotion
and didn't get it,
they need to speak up
as much as the woman
are speaking up.
I think that
management has to stop
punishing women for the
responsibilities they have
in their social
life, and actually
contribute to talking
to men about how
they have to do their share
so that problem wouldn't even
exist.
So a lot of corporations
take the excuse of, yeah,
but she might start a family,
or she might have kids soon,
and I don't think will
she be up for the job.
Instead of saying that, how
about telling all the fathers
in the company you
have to leave early
because you have a job to do?
I don't know, at
Google, you probably
don't have these problems
as many as other companies,
but you'll be amazed.
I've been exposed to so many
men shying away from saying,
I have to leave because
I want to do chores.
They say I want to leave
because I want to see my kids,
while the female
will say, I want
to leave because
I have bath time.
Not many males will stand up
and say, I have bath time.
They will say I'm
seeing my kids.
It's not a custody
battle where you have
viewership for your children.
You actually have to actively
stand up and say that's normal,
it's normalized.
Men have a lot to do.
And, of course, just being good
partners, colleagues, friends,
it's very helpful.
And changing our
language, I have
to insist on that
because we do tend
to use a lot of
female adjectives
negatively and male
adjectives positively.
And I'm not going to
mention what the words are.
They're not probably
censored, but we
have to change our language.
It's very, very important
because actions follow words,
and our words are
very important.
It's very, very important,
so stand up for each other
because we are in it
together, it matters.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Dina.
DINA: Firstly, thank you so
much for coming in and speaking
today.
SARAH ABDULLAH: Thank you.
DINA: I really enjoyed
hearing what you said.
One of the core elements
of gender diversity
is to really understand what
each side is going through.
As somebody who's
very knowledgeable,
can you share a
little bit of insight
about how you became
so knowledgeable.
And what you do to
increase your awareness.
SARAH ABDULLAH: I'm
a feminist at heart,
so I don't think there are
any limitations to what people
can do--
people are people.
But I also have a lot
of men in my life,
and I befriended both for
a very, very long time,
and just sharing
stories, connecting,
talking to each other,
seeing the side of men.
So I had a conversation
with a guy friend,
and I was telling
him, can you believe
this girl didn't
get a promotion?
Because it was known that
she would start a family.
And the company was reluctant
to give her a promotion
because, in their head, they
assumed she's going to leave.
Eventually, she's
going to leave.
Why should we invest in her?
Why should we give her
a promotion and a raise?
And it was very nice to
hear his side of this story
where he was telling me about
the same problem his wife was
facing.
And so when he was
talking about his wife,
he said it with so much
anger, and frustration,
and it's not fair, and
there is injustice,
while when it happened
at the company,
he didn't have
the same feelings.
And just being able to see not
that one person's point of view
is not consistent depending
on what social role they're at
was very interesting.
And it tells you that we
have a separation between how
we feel depending on where
we are in our social roles,
and maybe that is the problem.
If we were a better integrated,
if there was an integrated
ecosystem where
society, work, children
spoke more to each other, we
could find better solutions,
it would be very helpful.
But maybe from speaking
both to males, and females,
at work, and friends, and seeing
both sides of the same person
speaking differently.
And then bringing it
to their awareness,
or them bringing something
to my awareness, and just
continuous conversations,
just conversing with everybody
all the time.
SPEAKER 1: And I think there's
one thing that is unique
about you is that
you're curious,
and that you don't
necessarily settle for--
you'd like to get
your answers right.
And I can see you as a
child probably asking
a lot of questions.
SARAH ABDULLAH: Yeah, yes, I
do like to ask questions, I do.
I love debates, and
they're very healthy,
and they become
heated, but it's always
good to question something.
SPEAKER 1: Yep, absolutely.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
on the content space.
So it's also a topic
that's dear to us,
but I'd like to
get your insights
on what do you think the Arabic
landscape looks like today.
And how you see people
in the region responding
to your content?
Are people happy?
Do they want more?
What kind of feedback are
you getting about the content
that you're producing?
SARAH ABDULLAH: So
when we first started,
and we started
producing the content,
the feedback was
not always positive
because our characters
looked different.
For example, Makooky, when
Makooky started he had horns.
And my idea was these are
just satellite receptors,
and he's coming
from outer space.
And we started getting
a big backlash on that.
And we didn't realize that,
OK, that was a big no, no, no,
so we need to change it.
Where we are today is
definitely positive.
We're getting good feedback on
our content because we listen.
We look at our comments,
we look at our reviews.
We get a lot of comments on
our social media platforms.
And we work a lot
with academics to see
what they would like
in form of structure
so that we structure our
content in a specific way that
is age relevant.
But we also work a lot with
psychologists, nutritionists,
and emotional intelligence
coaches for children,
and we get their feedback
and we produce accordingly.
So there's always a
conversation about why are we
producing this content?
Because for us, it has to
be content with purpose,
be it educational
or entertaining.
And we look at the
purpose before looking
at just the piece of content.
In terms of where the
Arabic content is today,
I think a lot of
effort is being done.
Everybody's upping their
game on every level, be it
the creation, the content
itself, or the production.
The quality of the content
is getting better and better
because we are working with
a market that has exposure
to international content.
And the quality is wonderful.
And the content itself is so
studies and a lot of research
has gone behind it.
Our characters are loved.
And there are pieces that get
much more views than others,
much more likeability
than others.
And we realizing
more and more it's
everything that has more humor,
entertainment value, mistakes.
Children love to watch other
children do mistakes and fall
and bump their heads.
And they love lightness
and silliness,
and then they kind
of found their way.
And I think they relate to it.
They don't want to see heroes,
and people, and children
who never do mistakes,
who act so right,
and which often tends to
be the messaging here,
all the preaching.
So we're also adapting
to that and we're
making sure that we have more of
that happening in our content.
AUDIENCE: So you've
been thinking
about the character for a
while before you left your job.
At what point did you feel
ready to quit and to proceed
full time?
How much had you actually
gotten done before you did that?
SARAH ABDULLAH: Not much.
I thought that I will not
get much done before I quit.
So which is also--
There are two ways to doing it.
You either start working on
your business before you quit,
and once you see
something materializing,
you quit your job,
or you just say, OK,
the only way to move
forward with this
is if I disconnect, detached,
breakup, and start my new life.
And it's a character,
and that's my character.
I can't overlap.
I don't like overlapping
because I think
the separation happened here.
And the minute I was
attached to Makooky so much
I don't think I will be
doing my job very well.
So walking into the office
became just another day
at the office.
And it's not fair, and you
are kind of disconnected.
So I just left, and then started
focusing really on Makooky,
but the idea was there,
but not much of it
was materialized while
I was at my old job.
Plus, it was very demanding,
and the hours were very long,
and the meetings were
endless because that's
what corporates love to do.
So it was not easy
so I disconnected
and then started Makooky.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Give me a bit
about your start journey.
So I'm sure you started
with a romantic idea of what
you really wanted to do, right?
SARAH ABDULLAH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The idea that you are
really passionate about then.
Like you said, when
you sit across people
who are investing in your
business or your customers,
you usually tend to move away
and let the market guide you.
Did you have to make
such a movement?
If yes, how did
that make you feel?
SARAH ABDULLAH: Yes, and I
had to do that type of shift.
I still have to
do it, and I think
I will continue to do it because
there's the part of you that
is romantic.
And I have still a lot of
ideas that probably won't
see the light for a while
until I convert them
into a valid business,
ideas, and revenue streams.
But yes, you do tend to do
that, and it's not easy.
It's frustrating, it's
very, very frustrating
to the creative in me, and
there's always a conflict.
But then I also
understand that if I
don't make the business
side of it work,
I will never have
this creative outlet.
So I have to make it work, and
I have to do the compromises.
Now, the only difference
is I pick my battles.
So there are things
that I will not
do no matter what
happens because there
is no point in then going on if
you lose your brand identity.
That, I won't compromise on.
But there are things that
you give your character
a make over, you give
a touch here and there.
We introduce
dialects, for example,
so now the characters
speak Saudi, Emirati,
Egyptian, Lebanese,
and you do that, right?
But it cannot just be a dream
because if I just wanted
to produce what I
love to produce,
then I should have just
produced it myself and continued
as an artist-- probably had
the blog or had a social media
platform where I upload things.
But the minute it
becomes a business,
it has to make business sense--
it has to.
And I don't fight that
anymore because there's
no point fighting it and
still wanting people's money.
You just can't
have it both ways.
So it is frustrating,
but I do have two hats on
and I exchange them.
And it's funny,
because I do tend
to do the writing at night
and the business work
during the day.
So I have a time
split between both.
I can do both.
So at night I'm like horrible
at business, and during the day,
I'll meet my target--
that's the kind of thing.
It is frustrating, though,
it's very frustrating.
SPEAKER 1: So I
personally really enjoyed
listening to your
story and gained
a lot of valuable insights,
which I'm sure everyone shares.
So thank you so much.
It was a pleasure to have you.
SARAH ABDULLAH: Thank
you for having me.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
SARAH ABDULLAH:
That was so nice.
Thank you so much, really.